hey i'm alex and i love cinnamon rolls i
mean what's not to like they're gooey
they're a little crunchy they've got a
glaze but i've got to say cinnamon rolls
do take a bit of time and energy to make
we all have different schedules but i
believe truly that that should not mean
we don't get to eat cinnamon rolls so
today i'm going to show you how to make
a 4 minute a 40 minute and a 4 hour
version of a cinnamon roll let's roll so
we're going to start with a four-minute
cinnamon roll this one is super easy
super quick i'm going to start with the
filling it's just melted butter some
brown sugar and some cinnamon of course
i'm starting with the filling just so we
have it done by the time we make our
dough so we've got a little hack here
because it's a four minute cinnamon roll
i'm gonna be using pancake mix instead
of flour because it's already got its
leavening agent in there and we can skip
a couple steps all it takes is an egg
some vanilla some sugar some milk i'm
gonna mix this up
now we're gonna add in our pancake mix
now again this isn't a classic cinnamon
roll so don't come for me if you want a
cinnamon roll and a pinch this might
just do the trick so our dough is
looking pretty good got a little bench
flour on there and we're gonna do a
little kneading action it's pretty cool
that pancake mix works in this i mean a
lot of people have pancake mix in their
cupboards already once you got a smooth
ball
you're good so now i'm gonna roll this
out
i'm not a big measurer but we're going
for about an eight by six rectangle all
right we're good on rolling i'm gonna
start spreading the filling over this
super easy just try to get it all there
evenly now we're gonna roll this up i'm
going to try to do it pretty tightly so
we get a good swirl
and then kind of just push it along
we're going to cut this baby in half
oh yeah that's a swirl we're going to be
microwaving this cinnamon roll
so i just greased these to make sure
they come out easy and now i'm just
gonna pop in our little cinnamon rolls
how cute and for the final step i'm
gonna pop a teaspoon of water in here
this just makes sure that it doesn't get
too dry i'm gonna microwave these for a
minute 45 at medium power and then we'll
make our frosting
mix some powdered sugar with some milk
two ingredients in this super easy
that's a great consistency not too thick
not too thin we're making good time i
think i did that in under 10 seconds
let's go get our rules and then we can
eat all right we've got our mugs they're
looking pretty cute now i'm just gonna
pop on some of that glaze
yes
you can't have a cinnamon roll without
the glaze four minute cinnamon rolls
there you go i mean they're looking
pretty good smelling pretty good for a
microwave cinnamon roll the last thing
we've got to do is eat i guess you could
eat this anyway you could just eat it
with your hands i'll just go for the
center
i have to say those tastes pretty good
for how little effort they took to make
the taste is there sweet definitely
satisfying if you want a cinnamon roll
in a pinch but if you have a little more
time and want something a little more
classic i've got the cinnamon roll for
you so this 40-minute cinnamon roll
recipe is still super approachable but a
little bit closer to the classic so i've
got my flour already here in the bowl
i'm just gonna add all of our
ingredients so we got milk melted butter
and egg sugar baking powder salt and for
a final ingredient instant yeast so
instant yeast is pretty cool because you
don't have to wait to activate it like
you would active dry yeast and it's
super foolproof so pretty hard to kill
now we're gonna mix this all up so we're
looking for like a shaggy dough you got
a little more muscle in there once it
gets a little shaggier we're ready to
knead so i'm just gonna pop this onto
our surface and get in there
the dough should kind of come together
and you'll be able to poke it and it
will spring back our dough is looking
good i'm gonna pop that in our bowl
cover it with the towel and let it rest
while we make our filling all right now
on to our filling which is essentially
the same as our four minute filling we
got our brown sugar
our melted butter and our cinnamon when
i was a kid i used to like melt butter
and sugar and i would eat it as like an
after-school snack that's why i'm like
this guys it was all that butter and
sugar that i ate as a kid
all right our filling is looking
delicious good enough for me to eat but
uh i'll wait we're gonna roll out our
dough
first we're gonna flour the surface
so again i like to eyeball things but
we're going for like a 12 by 16 inch
rectangle she's looking beautiful we
should name her her name shall be
cheryl all right our girl cheryl is
looking snatched
we're gonna like slap on some makeup on
this girl she is going out tonight we're
just gonna put our filling all over
there we're gonna roll it up again i'm
going for like the tight roll because
the tighter you roll your cinnamon roll
the better swirl you're gonna have so
just take your time
there we go all right we're all rolled
up so now i'm gonna cut my dough into
nine equal pieces wow cheryl she's never
looked better we're going to pop these
in our greased pan
it's already greased just going to start
at the end just going to try to squeeze
them all in here all right they're
looking great a beautiful swirl layer in
there i'm going to pop these in the oven
at 375 for 20 20-25 minutes until light
golden brown and while they're baking
i'm gonna make our frosting we're making
a cream cheese frosting still super easy
we just got some powdered sugar cream
cheese and vanilla so this is gonna be a
little bit thicker consistency than the
glaze was but we want it to be
spreadable
a nice creamy texture
all right
delicious
now we're ready to frost
damn cheryl
she's looking good so there's really
again no rhyme or reason to this i'm
just gonna slap on some frosting you
gotta get an even layer on each these
are still a little warm so our frosting
should kind of melt down into those
swirly whirly crevices all right we're
frosty like the snowman
i'm just gonna take one of these babies
out of here look at that oh
my god i'm drooling this is more of like
your classic delicious cinnamon roll
perfect to impress your friends to share
with your friends and really all you
spent was 40 minutes let's taste it and
i think i'm gonna go straight for the
center oh my god guys this is like
heaven
mmm lots of stuff right there this
is all you need so obviously this is
delicious but if you want to see
something epic stick around for the next
one the four hour cinnamon roll well i
know what you're thinking how could we
make a four-hour cinnamon roll seems a
little excessive well
we're making a giant now i used to be
the queen of making things giant back in
the day sorry alvin but today we're
gonna get even crazier with a giant
banana walnut cinnamon roll i'm so
excited i'm so excited we're gonna start
with our warm milk
melted butter and sugar i'm just gonna
give this a stir so our liquids are warm
to about 100 to 110 degrees because we
are using active dry yeast instead of
the instant yeast the warm temperature
will help the yeast to bloom if it's too
hot it will kill the yeast if it's too
cold it won't bloom so i'm gonna spread
it in an even thin layer over top just
so it gets like the most surface area so
now we're gonna let this hang out for a
minute until the yeast gets fully now
i'm gonna add in our flour and mix this
all up again we're looking for that
shaggy dough so this is going to be a
little bit of a wetter dough than our
last one because we are doing a double
proof method this will ensure we get a
very fluffy cinnamon roll so i am just
going to cover this and let it sit in a
warm spot until it doubles in size it is
time to make the filling for this giant
banana walnut cinnamon roll this is
going to take your cinnamon roll to a
whole nother level all i have to do is
melt the butter
brown sugar
cinnamon and a little salt so i'm
cooking this until everything kind of
cooks down into a nice
saucy kind of thing before i add in our
bananas i'm gonna add in our bananas i
love anything banana flavored pretty
much banana bread banana cake banana
cinnamon roll if i had a show it would
be called make a banana at this point
all right so i'm gonna let this cook
down stirring in between for about five
to seven minutes we don't want the
bananas to be completely mush but we
want to let them break down a little bit
all right our filling is ooey it's gooey
we still got some of that chunk of
banana in there our philly is looking
good smelling even better i'm gonna go
get the dough and we are gonna roll out
this giant cinnamon roll
all right our dough has risen it's
doubled in size if you take a close look
you can see some of those air bubbles in
there and that is from our yeast that
was alive good thing
i didn't kill it
so to this dough i'm gonna add salt some
baking powder and some flour so i know
this is still feeling a lot like our
other recipe but we're about to get
crazy now i'm just gonna flip this onto
our surface
and get to kneeden so the purpose of
kneading is to develop the gluten in the
dough and that will help us get a very
smooth and elastic dough you want a nice
a nice looking no ball we're just going
to get straight into rolling so i'm
gonna roll this to the same dimensions
as the last one we're looking good we
are ready to spread our banana filling
so again we're just spreading this out
in an even layer and now i'm gonna hit
it with some chopped toasted walnuts
banana and walnut just goes so well
together and it's nice to have a little
bit of a crunch in here that is looking
great i need to cut this into some
strips so i'm first just going to cut
this in half and then i'm going to cut
each of those in half
okay so to make this thing giant start
by rolling this first strip try to again
roll it as tightly as possible so you
get that good looking swirl all right
i'm just going to pick up this piece and
roll that into this piece
oh man
okay last one
we can make it
maybe a little messy that's all right
[Music]
okay this monster
get it in there
i have to say it that's looking pretty
good honestly i would eat that straight
out of the pan right now
all right so i popped this in a 10 inch
cast iron skillet i'm gonna cover it
with plastic wrap and pop it in a warm
spot to let it rise and expand to the
edge of the pan it'll take about 30
minutes oh
man
this is wild
i feel like it's my child like it's a
baby
all right so i'm gonna bake this at 3 25
for 45 minutes uncovered and then 35
minutes covered in foil
blowing slow i know it takes a while but
it's gonna be worth it for this baby all
right we are so close to the finish line
i could almost taste it but we've got
one more thing to do and that is our
final frosting of the day another cream
cheese frosting but even more decadent
because we're adding butter to this one
so to this powdered sugar i'm gonna add
some milk some cream cheese some melted
butter
and some vanilla
again just gonna mix this up
so we wanna get this nice and smooth so
that the sugar is all incorporated
all right
frosting is done our bun is out of the
oven welcome to the world big guy so i'm
gonna frost this thing of course the
final touch on this four hour ordeal i
have to say four hours flew by this is a
fun thing to do beautiful
and i'm gonna top it finally with some
more of our toasted chopped walnuts this
is definitely a dish to impress and
there you have it a four hour giant
banana walnut cinnamon roll it's crazy
it's beautiful you got the texture in
there from the walnuts you got the
gooeyness from the banana caramel
filling you've got the cinnamon roll you
got everything and now all that's left
to do is eat moment of truth
oh
i'm speechless
it actually looks very beautiful i must
say
okay
oh my god guys this is gonna be my
wedding cake
it's perfect you get every element that
you love of a cinnamon roll but then
that banana flavor pops right in there
to say hello and you're like where have
you been all my life 10 out of 10. okay
so we just busted out a four minute
a 40 minutes and a four hour cinnamon
roll i might have a favorite i know
you're not supposed to pick a favorite
child but if you have a favorite let me
know in the comments below if you make
any one of these please share and tag me
i'd love to see
and i
am gonna go finish this thing oh and
remember
there's always time to cook
oh yes
[Music]
you